BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY
OH SAY CAN BUSEY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
SLANDER AND LIBEL LAWS ARE
STRICT IN THIS COUNTRY, BUT I
CAN SAY THE FOLLOWING CONFIDENT
NO COURT WOULD EVER CONVICT ME--
GARY BUSEY IS A ( BLEEP )
LUNATIC.
IN THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE!
AND HIS TWITTER ACCOUNT IS JUST
MORE SUPPORTING EVIDENCE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A
PORTION FROM THE REAL TWEET
FROM @THEGARYBUSEY, AND FOR 250
POINTS, YOU NEED TO FILL IN THE
BLANK.
WE TRIED TO GET THE BUSE TO COME
ON AND READ THE TWEETS, BUT HIS
MANAGER SAID HE WAS TIED UP
CHUGGING SNAKE VENOM AND
THROWING TRASH AT THE MOON.
BUT WE DID THE NEXT BEST THING,
LIVE FROM A BUNKER IN AN
UNDISLOWSED LOCATION, GARY
BUSEY'S ACTUAL BROTHER, LARRY
BUSEY.
>> WE'RE LIVE NOW, CHRIS
HARDWICK.
IT'S ME, LARRY BUSEY.
IT IS AN HONOR TO SERVE WITH YOU
ON TELEVISION RIGHT NOW.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, THAT IS
DEFINITELY GARY BUSEY'S BROTHER.
FIRST ONE, BLANK CAME TO SEE HOW
I WAS DOING TODAY.
BLANK CAME TO SEE HOW I WAS
DOING TODAY.
AL.
>> FUTURE BUSEY, EMPEROR OF THE
PSYCHE WARD.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, ALL RIGHT.
POINTS FOR THAT.
RHYS.
>> THE BLOKE I KILLED LAST WEEK.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THE ACTUAL
ANSWER WAS.
>> SILVER BACKED WHALES WITH
HIGH OCEAN SPRAY CAME TO SEE HOW
I WAS DOING TODAY.
HI, SWEETHEART.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE, PLANET EARTH
IS THE ONLY BLANK.
PLANET EARTH IS THE ONLY
BLANK, JIM.
>> PLANET EARTH IS THE ONLY
PLACE THAT WON'T TAKE MY CHECKS.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINT.
( APPLAUSE )
THE CORRECT BUSEY-ISM IS...
( LAUGHTER )
>> PLANET EARTH IS THE ONLY
VACATION SPOT FOR ADVANCED
CLOWNS.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE, THE SUN
SETTING OVER THE OCEAN MAKES
BLANK.
JIM.
>> THE SKY DARK.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: THAT IS WAY TOO
COHERENT A THOUGHT, BUT I'LL
GIVE YOU POINTS FOR IT.
IT'S SO HARD TO OUT-WEIRD HIM.
LET'S FIND OUT.
>> THE SUN SETTING OVER THE
OCEAN MAKES AN EXCLAMATION MARK
IN REVERSE.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: IT DOES.
>> IT REALLY DOES.